[Music]
on this Sunday night Israel ramps up its
retaliation Israel's military sends more
soldiers into Gaza and scales up air
strikes as the destruction and
Desperation
grows pressure builds to bring hostages
home bringing them home should be uh the
first priority now I'm afraid the freak
and fatal accident on the ice the tragic
death of a former NHL player and a
legacy of laughs you have to stop the
Q-tip when there's
resistance the fond farewell to beloved
friend Matthew
Perry global national with baren Asser
good evening Israel is stepping up its
assault inside Gaza pummeling the
Palestinian territory teritory with
waves of air strikes and is sending even
more soldiers after Israeli Defense
Forces say they hit hundreds more Hamas
targets overnight new video released by
the IDF shows armored vehicles and
troops advancing into Northern Gaza part
of what Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu says is the second phase of
Israel's three-week old war against
Hamas there are scenes of death and
destruction all over the Palestinian
Enclave tonight gaza's Health Ministry
operating under Hamas says more than
8,000 Palestinians have been killed by
Israeli shelling the more than 2 million
people who live in Gaza are extremely
desperate struggling to find food water
and
Medicine according to Israeli officials
more than 14400 people were killed
during the Hamas attack in southern
Israel on October 7th Israel says it's
war against hamas's retaliation for the
atrocities committed a warning some of
the images you're about to see in our
coverage is disturbing Danielle Hamin
has our top story from Jerusalem tonight
Danielle the situation inside Gaza is
growing more dire by the day far more
eight trucks crossed into Gaza today
bringing in food water and medicine
that's now a total of 117 trucks since
they first opened the Border 9 days ago
just to give you an idea that's still
only a quarter of what would normally go
in on a single
day every sunrise in Gaza reveals a new
level of
Destruction and Desperation overnight
residents broke into United Nations
warehouses and distribution centers to
get their hands on basic things like
flour the UN warns civil order is
starting to break down the latest
directive by the Israeli military the
evacuation of aloud's Hospital currently
housing up to 15,000 wounded and
displaced according to the director
the Israeli Army told us this is going
to be a military zone Israel says it's
now in the next phase of the war against
Hamas and has repeatedly implied Al
shifa Hospital the biggest in Gaza could
be a
Target Hamas the IDF claims is operating
a command center beneath the hospital
underground Doctors Without Borders told
Global News Today their staff have seen
no evidence of that situation in the
shiffer hospital is
extremely dire uh we are running out of
almost everything in terms of supplies
and
consumables the most basic dressings the
most basic medication most basic
painkillers children undergo surgery
with no morphine and the generators
running on fuel have almost nothing left
in the tank but it appears Hamas hasn't
run out the group needs fuel to launch
rockets and Rockets have not stopped
falling on Israel but that's not all one
of the key uses of fuel is also to
ventilate that subway system if you will
that underground tunnels where Hamas has
its
operations um and so one of the key
reasons that Israel had been looking to
cut off fuel was in order to prevent
that ventilation to essentially
suffocate them out of tals and bring
them above ground if that is indeed the
case how many more weeks or months worth
of fuel does Hamas have left in stock in
the meantime it's the innocent on the
ground who pay a heavy price local
journalists working with global news
stumbled Upon A little boy named alar
today I'm a Canadian Palestinian I I
lived in Canada for seven years and then
I moved to Palestine I had lots of
friends and now I don't know of them
because of the war I wish this war could
end and all my family would become safe
and I could just go back to my school in
an unannounced visit today the top
prosecutor of the international criminal
court went to the Rafa border between
Gaza and Egypt today he wasn't allowed
inside Gaza but later said obstructing
relief supplies could constitute a crime
under the ICC jurisdiction
Farah Danielle Haman in Jerusalem
tonight thank you Danielle as Israel
escalates attacks on Gaza concern is
increasing for the more than 200
hostages taken by Hamas the son of a
Canadian woman believed to be among them
is pushing for diplomacy arguing that
gives his mother and other captives the
best chance of being released the
Israeli military maintains rescuing the
hostages is still a primary goal Mike
Armstrong is in Jerusalem tonight as
well and he's looking at the push and
pull between military action and
diplomacy it's not certain but we have
reason to believe he is holding on to
Hope speaking to the Jerusalem Press
Club Sunday Jonathan Zan says he spent
the last 23 days since his mother
disappeared working every lead he can to
find out if she's still alive in Arabic
it's maafi enough Israeli Canadian
Vivien silver is a peace activist she
had Palestinian contacts her family
won't say who they've spoken to or what
they've been told but they're trying to
stay
optimistic that as the Israeli military
hits Gaza exactly where silver would
likely be held Zan says he'd rather see
diplomacy now I'm afraid than military
action bringing them home should be uh
the first priority well the Israeli
government spent the weekend trying to
reassure families of the hostages there
were multiple meetings Sunday it was the
defense minister meeting with families
Saturday it was the Prime
Minister Benjamin Netanyahu told the
families the goal of the operation is
still to free the hostages but insist to
do that the key is to put as much
pressure on Hamas as possible now some
families protested Sunday arguing
hitting Hamas while hoping to get the
hostages back is the wrong strategy I I
truly afraid that these two goals is
like um in conflict with each other I
ask the authorities here and all the
International Community to to keep
pushing they are reassuring that now Zan
has been in contact with Canadian
officials and told they're working their
contacts there is also another Canadian
believed to be held hostage Judy
Weinstein I don't know how much power
Canada has but uh it seems like they're
very much invested in doing everything
they can we are organizing Zan says
before October 7th his mother pushed for
peace and the woman he knew would be
pushing the same thing today but he says
it's possible she's changed he says he's
nervous about the trauma she's being
through and what it might mean to come
back to her house burned and so many
members of her community killed
Farah Mike Armstrong in Jerusalem thank
you Mike Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin
netan who is fending off his critics
tonight he's apologized on social media
about a post that blamed Israel's
military and its security service for
the Hamas attacks on October 7th now the
most prominent critic of netanyahu's
comment was a member of Israel's
emergency Unity government and a former
Armed Forces Chief of Staff as Redmond
Shannon reports Netanyahu is being
slammed for playing the blame
game Benjamin Netanyahu at Sea with
Israel's Navy on Sunday just as his
messaging toward his Security Forces
could be described as all at
Sea on Saturday the Israeli Prime
Minister again said he would be among
those to answer questions about the
intelligence failures that led to the
October 7th amass attack but only after
the war he was joined at the news
conference by defense min yuav Galant
and War cabinet minister and former
Defense Forces Chief Benny Gant but just
a few hours later Netanyahu posted on
social media that at no time was he
warned of hamas's war and tensions and
that security and military officials had
assessed Hamas was looking for a
settlement gance responded saying when
we are at War leadership must display
responsibility make the correct
decisions and strengthen the forces the
Prime Minister must must retract his
statement Netanyahu deleted his post
Sunday morning and said I was wrong and
I apologize for that I give full backing
to all the heads of the security
services in the end he understood that
his government would fall apart unless
he behaved properly and uh he took it
back and Professor Jonathan Reinhold
believes Israeli soldiers and their
leaders will see this as just a small
distraction from their task at hand n
yahu became Israel's longest Serving
Leader by assuring citizens he would
protect them but also by knowing how to
protect himself many many people have
very little faith in his
Integrity everyone's got faith in his
intellectual and political capabilities
Netanyahu spoke with US President Joe
Biden again Sunday the White House says
they discussed the hostage situation and
that Biden underscored the need to
increase the flow of Aid into Gaza
Redmond Channon Global News
London now in the backdrop of the
expanded Israeli offensive and Gaz at
Global News has information about the
presence of a small team of Canadian
special forces in Israel who deployed
sometime after October 7th our Auto buau
Chief Mercedes Stevenson has more on the
deployment
Mercedes far Global News has learned
that Canadian Special Operations forces
including the country's most elite and
secretive unit jtf2 have deployed to
Israel according to multiple sources
with direct knowledge the special force
troops will be engaged in assessing
threats to the Canadian embassy any
required Embassy Security and evacuation
of that takes place and they will also
be liasing with the IDF Major General
Dennis Thompson has retired but he was
the commander of the Canadian Special
Operations forces as well as an observer
mission in the Sinai today on the west
block he explained the role of the
Canadian Special Operations forces in a
conflict like this typically Cana or the
Canadian Special Operations forces
deploys to crisis areas using what's
called a immediate response task force
so that they can draw the capabilities
that they need from across the entire
Canadian Special Operations forces
command which includes jtf2 and other
units and because they're on such a high
state of Readiness they can get into the
theater rather quickly can off Comm
deployed troops to Israel in response to
the security situation after October 7th
the command has deployed its Elite
troops into similar circumstances before
including Sudan Afghanistan and Ukraine
General Thompson explained what the
mission may look like there are still
two Canadians missing I believe they
could well be hostages in which case
they may be part of the hostage rescue
planning uh I don't know that for
certain but this is typical to to send
uh to send the immediate response task
for for to an area that's in crisis and
that could be something as simple as
protecting the embassy uh it could be
they could be involved in uh assisting
the Israelis with their planning far to
be clear there's no suggestion that the
Canadian Special Operations forces are
fighting in Gaza but multiple sources
say they are fulfilling a critical role
when it comes to Canada's ability to
engage with the IDF and provide Safety
and Security for the
embassy Mercedes Stevenson in Ottawa
thank you Mercedes tragedy on the ice in
England coming up these safety measures
being considered after the death of a
hockey player plus battling demons while
bringing smiles to fans remembering
actor Matthew
[Music]
Perry in the 1930s the matey Village of
St meline Manitoba was burned To The
Ground by the government to make a
community pasture for cattle to graze
for a weekend every summer hundreds of
descendant still Gather in that field
340 km west of Winnipeg to stay
connected to their community and their
culture now with a new government in
Manitoba and for the first time a first
nation's Premier there's new hope that
next year's Gathering could celebrate
getting that land back Melissa Rin
reports fresh off an election Victory
Premier wab Cano had words that many
mate in the province had waited
generations to hear there are many
specific priorities of the matey people
and the mate nation and one of them is
St
meline and so I want to signal to
you so I want to signal to you that that
I know that this is an important
priority in 1938 the federal government
burned down the village while families
were away for the summer working like
Vernon dy's parents and when they came
back in the middle of October their
house was already burnt down and uh
their dog was shocked 35 homes a church
and school leveled to make way for a
6,700 hectare Community pasture today
only the cemetery remains there are the
grave sites that you continue to visit
and take care of and honor that there is
a history there that must be addressed
chartran says with the land back in the
hands of our families and our nation the
opportunity to tell this story means
that we can remind Canadians that we are
a country that is better than these
historic actions showed us to be the
association of Manitoba Community
pastors managed the land that currently
serves 40 cattle Farmers they say they
will not oppose the province giving the
land back to the mate descendants like
dney are already dreaming of what could
be if it's in my lifetime I want a house
over
there you already got your spoted I got
my spot picked out already Melissa rgen
Global News
Winnipeg bringing the world laughs while
battling addiction next morning the loss
of Matthew Perry
[Music]
what a small world and yet I never run
into
Beyonce that of course is Canadian actor
Matthew Perry is the very sarcastic
Chandler Bing on Friends the hitet Cal
that catapulted him to a household name
tonight fans all around the world are
mourning his death according to the LA
Times police sources say the star was
found unresponsive yesterday afternoon
in his Los Angeles area home Home Police
have also stated Foul Play does not seem
to be a factor Jia isri is looking at
how Perry's being remembered as a
comedic genius and how his life was
marred by some very serious trouble as
well how do I look oh um I don't
care all the cast members of friends got
laughs but none could land a joke like
Chandler B I left the message I have
some pride do you no
best known as the quirky and
quick-witted character Chandler Bing the
actor was found dead at his Los Angeles
home Saturday police say the 54-year-old
drowned in his hot tub the sudden death
of a star who helps cement friends as a
cultural
phenomenon Perry made the character his
own with his perfect timing and pure
sarcasm could I be more
sorry he also starred in a string of hit
movies chewy hi Luke Skywalker while the
audience was laughing few knew Perry was
struggling with addiction by the time I
was 18 I was drinking I was drinking
every day during the 2021 Friends
reunion Perry discussed using
prescription drugs and alcohol to cope
to me I felt like I was going to die if
they didn't laugh things got so bad he
could not remember three entire years of
filming I have it's the time I should
have been the toast of the town I was in
a dark room meeting
with nothing but drug dealers police
sources told the LA Times no drugs were
found at the scene and they do not
suspect foul
play after the discovery Perry's family
arrived at his La home including his
Canadian mother Suzanne Morrison once
press secretary to Pierre Elliot Trudeau
and his stepfather Canadian broadcaster
Keith Morrison Perry was born in
Massachusetts his dad was American actor
John Bennett Perry when his parents
divorced he moved to Ottawa where he and
the current prime minister met his
classmates who gets recognized more in
Canada you or Trudeau I would say
Trudeau Justin Trudeau tweeted I'll
never forget the schoolyard games we
used to play thanks for all the laughs
Matthew you were loved and and you will
be missed you have to stop the Q-tip
when there's
resistance outside the New York
apartment Perry and his castmates
popularized fans left tributes I loved
Chandler I loved the show and I also
knew remember this because it's going to
be the best time of your life and I knew
it Lisa
kudra that's global national for this
Sunday night I'm faren AER and on behalf
of our whole crew I want to thank you so
much for spending part of your evening
with us we're going to leave you tonight
with scenes from outside Matthew Perry's
home in Los Angeles where fans are
laying flowers at his doorstep in
tribute Donna will be back with you
tomorrow until next time take care of
yourselves and take care of each other
good
night
[Music]